at some point though you then make the
decision that you're gonna do the
writing and the books and the courses
when did you write the 90 day screenplay
book then I need the 1980 novel came out
in 2010 the 90 day screenplay was I
don't know maybe 2012-13 something like
that okay
is there a chapter in the 90 day
screenplay book that is most contested
or people have the most questions about
one part of the process I'm not really
aware of anything being particularly
contested I get a lot of people who love
it but it is I think different than a
lot of the screen writing books out
there and I think it's my perception of
it is is that it's it's very much about
process and and less about results and I
think that when we lose ourselves in the
process the results can take care of
themselves
and one of the things that that I teach
here's my cat I don't know if you're
picking that up there's captain but one
of the things that is that I talk about
is how dilemma is the source of the
story and a lot of writing books talk
about the dramatic problem and the
implication for with that for me and and
why I I was resistant to a lot of the
writing books that I read is that
problems are solved their intellectual
you solve a problem dilemmas are
resolved through ships through a shift
in perception and so something I I sort
of I didn't discover this but I sort of
drilled down into it is that the source
of our story is our protagonists dilemma
and a dilemma is a problem that can't be
solved without creating another problem
you know you've got a story when what
your protagonist wants is impossible to
achieve based on their current approach
or their current identity okay in other
words it's going to necessitate a shift
in person
okay they're going to have to become a
sort of new person so to speak by the
end of the story so you know like when
you think about problems you think about
like I have a flat tire I call triple-a
they solved my problem okay not an
interesting story but if I have a flat
tire and I'm out in the desert I call
triple-a and this guy and I'm dying of
thirst and this guy drives out to the
desert and it's the guy who's sleeping
with my wife now I've got an interesting
story now I want to kill the man who's
here to save my life okay so when you
can connect to your protagonists dilemma
then you've got something to work with
the dilemma is the source of your story
and if you look at any great story
you've got a clear dilemma okay and when
you can connect to that then then you've
got something to work with so that's one
of the things that I help writers with
is understanding the dilemma but it's a
more holistic way you know it's it's not
like it's not like let's figure out your
prop your premise the premise is born
out of the protagonists dilemma okay and
so it's I just think it's it's it's for
me it's a more organic way of working
and then you start to see how plot
emerges out of the characters struggle
okay so when I start to and I'm not
talking about in election well
intellectualizing the dilemma be key
because you can't problems are solved
they're gonna let you can't figure out
when you try and figure out your
protagonist dilemma you get stuck but
when you start to connect here to the
experience of the dilemma all sorts of
images and ideas and situations start to
emerge to support that and and and so
that's sometimes people call that the
brainstorming part of the the process
and so the the first part of the 90 day
screenplay is just doing a lot of free
writing imagining your character or your
protagonists in relationship to other
characters and before you start to put a
framework around it or start to in
done any kind of structure for it do you
think some people get very confused
thinking their dilemma is their problem
and it's not like when you were talking
to the prisoners were they very clear
about what the problem was in their
story maybe you didn't get into all that
with them I don't know if I got into
that with them I can't remember that but
sometimes writers get confused about the
difference between problem and dilemma
and you know problems are solved so that
like I you know if I said well that's
that that's solvable it's not a it's
it's an aspect of the dilemma you know
like if if in other words here's let's
let's a part of the story could be that
I get a flat tire and I have to get my
flat tire fixed but the dilemma is is in
other words there's a jumping all over
the place here there's a movement to a
scene and so if a scene begins with a
problem like I got a flat tire and at
the end of this at the end of the scene
I get my flat tire fixed and nothing
else happens we don't have a story what
has to happen is by the end of the scene
I can get my flat tire fixed but
something else happens that's going to
lead the story in a new direction in
other words my dilemma wasn't the flat
tire the dilemma is my false belief
about what the flat tire means I don't
know that makes sense but in other words
sometimes
here's what writers get stuck writers
think when you hear the term dramatic
problem dramatic problem you assume or
you may assume that it's your job to
figure out your characters solution to
their problem
Einstein says you can't solve a problem
at the same level of consciousness that
created the problem in other words it's
not difficult it's impossible
you're never gonna figure out your
protagonists transformation but what you
know so so what you don't want to do is
you don't want to think that your
character is is a clean line from the
beginning to the end of the story
you want you need to understand that
your protagonist is going to die at the
end of Act two they're gonna die to
their old identity I don't mean they're
physically gonna die but they're gonna
die too they're they're they're they're
going to be forced to surrender the
meaning they made out of their goal when
Jimmy Stewart leaves Bedford Falls then
he'll have a wonderful life the end of
act 2 is my life is worth I'm worth more
dead than alive
okay so he dies to his old identity he
and you know it's it's it's a great
moment where he jumps off the bridge he
wants to jump he wants to commit suicide
he wants to jump into the icy water now
I love this image because Clarence jumps
into the icy water and so the action is
the same this yeah nobody ever questions
this but he jumps in to save somebody
else so he doesn't he doesn't die he's
you know he's reborn and that's the
beginning of Act three
you